two of the Trump administration's
controversial immigration policies are
under challenged this morning and the
outcome could limit the president's
power a federal judge ruled yesterday
the decision to end the daca program
that protects young immigrants from
deportation was unlawful and the Supreme
Court holds arguments this morning on
the president's travel ban Jan Crawford
is outside the Supreme Court all right
so Jan what will the justices have to
decide here
well Norah they're looking actually a
president Trump's third try at a travel
ban and this one is significantly more
limited in the earlier ones it targets
only a handful of countries that the
administration says don't have proper
security screening in place for people
who are coming to the US and the Supreme
Court actually let this ban take effect
back in December which i think is a sign
that the justices may well rule for the
administration in this case but
challengers say that the band still
discriminates against Muslims it targets
them because of their religion or their
nationality and they're using the
president's own words his tweets his
campaign promises to try to make their
case and a decision in this issue is
expected by the end of June Norah be
interesting to watch that we mentioned
that the Trump administration received
that lower case court rather setback to
end daca explain what the judge said
there well I mean this is a decision
from one federal judge and he's just
said that the administration didn't do a
good enough enough job of explaining why
was ending this program which of course
as you said protects us some young
adults from deportation but whether or
not this is a setback I mean that still
remains to be seen because he gave the
administration 90 days to come up with a
better explanation for why they were
ending this program and if they don't
then he said he's going to keep those
daca protections in place and it's also
important to remember that this is just
one judge there are several other lower
court rulings they've come down on both
sides of this issue so you know what
that means the Supreme Court probably is
going to have to step into this case at
some point although that won't be
anytime soon
and lucky us Jen will be there to
explain it all to us Jen thank you so
much thanks I was thinking that exactly
saying right now no one makes it clear
that I was in Jan Crawford exactly what
I was thinking